oh look at this setup okay that's a
quick start why are you going so fast
didn't you have you seen this position
before
yeah and white just rattled off that
first move like oh yeah it's this
position I'm familiar with it I've
played several games with this opening
with this setup okay well I think I'm
gonna play the copycat game Wow
you need to slow down well if I do this
there might be c3 d4 wait a second
no I could do this I was thinking Knight
g5 because this is unprotected that's
usually the first thing I do okay
actually there's two points unprotected
a7 and h7 okay the bishop is hitting
this pawn whoo but wait a second I think
this is very good very good have to get
rid of that bishop and now there's not
going to be any castling on this side of
the board uh-oh now do I take or do I
support it with my queen and then
something like a Yugoslav attack queen
queen e7 pawn push that seems a bit
far-fetched don't you think don't you
think that that's far-fetched let's just
take that guy I don't want to I don't
want to do that so now there's no
castling in this direction so he's
either gonna have to stay put here or go
in this direction in order to castle in
this direction the Queen and the bishop
need to move where would they be moving
where would they be moving let's get my
knight out which is a really gonna be a
better square than that one
if this Oh white has to be very cautious
of the dark squares that was the good
bishop maybe I should be pressing
forward in the center oh that might be a
good idea no it also might not be a good
idea I was just ready to do this but the
similar thing would happen to me then
I'm not a big fan of that
how about Knight right here all right
now so that if my opponent plays this
Knight I could kick it away and now this
bishop can develop so easily because of
the pressure I have on g2 so I think
getting rid of my knight on f4 becomes a
number one a number one task but I'm
starting to actually not like my
decision to play Knight f4 but I'm not
going to share why because I have I have
some fear that maybe my opponent might
be listening so I'm not going to give
any tips ah
okay what about just kicking this night
away let's get him out of there oh whoa
whoa whoa my heart just skipped a beat
there because there might be the
possibility for a knight check I take
and if there was able to be a queen or
even a rook landing on one of these two
squares it'd be made how devastating
would that have been well there might
even be some to move combo that would be
working out no there wouldn't were there
no I'll be able to defend if that
happens right yeah they want to do that
would they it's a day that I'm playing
by the way
I don't play individuals i play teams
they they wouldn't do that
what are they collaborating on right now
that definitely got scary right there
Knight check takes oh that would have
been oh that would have stung okay
um earlier by the way I was fearful when
I played Knight f4 I was fearful of d4
right away braking at this point and I
felt it uncomfortable to support it with
d6 at the time because white would take
this rook and I couldn't take with my
queen because I'd be dropping this pawn
and if I took with my King then I lose
the right to castle in either direction
so anyhow not the case right now now my
knight can retreat just like their
knight retreated and I'm still looking
to castle in what direction I'll
probably end up going King side I need
to move my Queen in order to do that if
I want a queenside castle I need to move
my rook if the D file opens up I'd be
more inclined I believe to Castle
queenside because it throws my rook
right on this file now what 42nd lead
for my opponent I have pressure on this
pawn I didn't realize until just right
now what do you do about that my bishop
is going to see the world soon enough
but I want a first castle I could do it
now since there isn't going to be a
bishop a6 my knight isn't a pin however
and I don't like pins and neither should
you
and neither should you you should not
like pins either no you shouldn't this
nights gonna play here what a bug what a
bug all right how about this right now I
can't get out of this pin so easily I
don't I don't want this night to post
here if the knight post here I want to
be able to take it and unless I have
another piece that's going to watch over
this square then that wouldn't be
available because of the recapture and a
position you don't want to be in is
where you're pinned piece is being hit
from all these different angles so what
does this mean what does this mean okay
it means right now my knight is feeling
a lot of pressure does
like that not at all so let's go here I
want a castle next
could I just Castle and get out of this
pin um
it's tight game 30-second advantage I
just want a castle I'm definitely
wanting to Castle kingside went up the
other thing to point was when I if I
were to still down just a single square
I mean Castle if I were to castle or if
I were to just go a single square I
would still have possibilities more
reasonable possibilities of let's say oh
it's couch like that half open file 1
square I have I retain the option to go
Queen side two squares I'm really not
okay so I have a lot of space this pond
is unprotected where with my knight left
to be where did where's his home where
is his home where does he want to reside
why did I do that why did I do that why
did I do that one I don't have good
answers to that okay I have to just
start going fast I was thinking more
long-term I want my knight to somehow
get here how do I don't know how I do
that though let's double up first double
those rookies mmm I can't deal with that
Knight my queen is now acting like a
bishop to box out the night I want to
remove him whoa first this this Knight
needs to go and then my queen has come
over here to get rid of this Queen arm
is there an IG for move oh man okay come
over here clean your job is now to get
rid of this Queen over here the pieces
that are directly in my territory or
even threatening to enter my territory
ah they're in a pre move they missed
that Queen move right there that's oh
that's a dropped Queen right there
my queen is going to she's tough now
she's having to uh beat out a pawn here
Queen versus pawn it's the clean versus
pawn trick right sneaky move right there
really anything is going to win but down
out a queen stuff falls stuff falls fast
it was a tight game up to that point
real tight
just wanting to trade where are those
trades push looking for stalemate little
stalemate
one two alright good game
ah man was in a primo if I guess or
something just missed that the Queen's
sneaking back there to kick out that
Queen let me go back here interesting so
I think I was well one one thing easily
missed you know you just get into the
habit of oh I'm just gonna fee and cut
out but that King is not on its original
square there I do have that possibility
I think this is something to stay out of
the way of um because now it turns out
you have like a fiend kettled rook
that's he's just out of play you you
know you don't have the option to go
queenside castle anymore and this right
here this is still a little bit scary to
me I have to say cuz even the threat to
play like night here I have to take
Queenie the threat of Queen III to c3
it's a little bit awkward to me I can't
I can't move my Brooke I can't move this
pawn I can't move this rook so I'd have
to move this pawn very limited well with
what my next move would be but anyhow
even even backing up as soon as I played
my Knight to f4 I think you have a d4
move to undermine my pond
again if I do d6 I think you take on
this square and at least stop me from
castling but you know what then again if
your rug takes Mayan it's almost like
you're on castled as well all right like
you you don't have the option to castle
in either direction either okay it's
only how I think d4 was worth the closer
look right here as soon as I post it up
on f4 and okay I'm in an awkward pin for
right now I don't know if there's a
better way to maybe exploit this pin
maybe is d4 move well I guess you'd be
dropping this pawn could get a little
messy but okay Castle I don't have any
I'm really not feeling like I have any
problems at this point so my suggestions
are really just further back my opponent
did well to finally get that rook
working going to be won and coming back
I think f4 at this point is the next
potential pawn break to look into maybe
just right now actually instead of
bringing the bishop back why not f4
right now
f4 with maybe even f5 as the idea and if
I take out of the rook or pond I could
see as a recapture but anyhow I guess
that would be the next pawn break to try
and get in clean Lina's lost if the
Queen takes Queen who stands better I
think there's possibilities for maybe me
having a good night versus a bad Bishop
since these guys are on the same color
as him if I could somehow get my knight
to this square I'm not sure still be a
tough battle if we just had the exchange
of Queens okay good game let me close
out